thumbs up if everybody can hear me
no we got a few thumbs up everybody if
you can hear me
raise it up a little bit more thumbs up
in the back back there you can hear me
everybody good
my name is bakari sellers hello hello
i am from the strom law firm in columbia
south carolina
um i stand here today with uh
chantel cherry lassiter to my left
chase lynch to my right chance i give
you
chase chance lynch to my right harry
daniels
to my far right uh benjamin crump who's
not with us today
um we have the honor of representing the
family of
andrew brown jr uh
i know khalil and jarrod are here with
me
and i first want to say that
my heart goes out to these two young men
who had to witness on video
uh the murder of their father uh
unlike dare i say anyone else out here
today they had to go through and endure
something
over the last two hours that not many of
us can ever imagine
and so for that my prayers and my heart
go out to both of them
and their family and this community for
the loss
of andrew brown jr
i actually want to say thank you to
everyone who made this viewing possible
i know that your honor stated that we
had 10 days to view it
but they work diligently to allow us to
see these videos 20 minutes
of what i believe to be two minutes but
we feel it two hours excuse me but we
feel as if it tells the entire story
of what happened that day with andrew
brown jr
a question was asked of me i believe by
brian todd
as i was walking in and he asked me what
do we expect to see
i said we anticipate seeing an
unjustified
killing what we saw on that video
was an unjustified killing
what we saw on that video is something
that we believe also
denotes further investigation and does
have some
criminal liability the way we're going
to do this today is i want
to bring both uh
mr lynch and ms lasseter up
to talk about what he was able to see on
the video
will then have words from the family
then we'll have words
from mr daniels
and then i'll come back up and we'll
take as many questions as we possibly
can
to get these young men back home and on
their way so with that i want to pass it
to
a great lawyer who we brought on for
this purpose who's done an amazing job
and i want
everyone who's under the sound of my
voice to know how good both of these
lawyers are
uh and how we stand with them in their
truth
particularly ms lassiter having to
undergo some of the words that have been
coming her way
good afternoon my name is chance lynch
i am the managing partner at lynch law
i am a former assistant district
attorney
criminal defense attorney civil attorney
civil rights attorney
let me say first the honor and privilege
it is to serve
with these colleagues and with this
legal team to assist them
and i'm grateful for the privilege to be
able to serve alongside them as we serve
this family
today i was able to sit with
two of mr brown's sons as we
watch several videos we were able to see
six videos today and i'm grateful for
the kindness
and the hospitality that the sheriff's
office has shown
during our tenure here while viewing
these videos
the first video that we were able to see
did not have any audio it was the dash
cam
the last five were all body cam we were
able to hear
words spoken and we were able to see
some critical footage that i think
yields
um truth transparency to what we've
all thought we would see from the
beginning in fact what
i saw today absolutely corroborates
what attorney lasseter shared with us
when she was only able to see 20 seconds
now i'm not sure what footage
the district attorney has seen i can
only go
based off of what he has said and what
he has insinuated
well we we have a saying where i'm from
and that saying is i was born at night
but not last night all right
and so we were able to see mr brown
sitting in his vehicle
as he was ambushed and as the sheriff's
office made their way to his residence
appearing to be surprised it appears
that he was possibly on the phone
at all times his hands were visible
at all times you can see that he was not
a threat
there was a shot fired when the shot was
fired
he put the car in reverse putting
several feet if not yards
away from the police who were there he
turned his wheel to the left
to turn it away from the law enforcement
officers at no
point did we ever see any police
officers behind his vehicle
at no point did we ever see mr brown
make contact
with law enforcement we
we were able to see where they possibly
reached out to make contact to him
but we did not see any actions on
mr brown's part where he made contact
with them
or tried to go in their direction in
fact he did just the opposite
while there was a group of law
enforcement that were in front of him he
went the opposite direction
as he turned to the left to go across
his yard
a second shot was fired and as he began
to accelerate
and increase his speed um tracks of mud
began to appear in the yard
and when his car was clearly across the
yard
at all times what we saw were police
officers standing
on the pavement unloading their weapons
they there were so many shots
that we found difficulty in counting the
number of shots
that his vehicle received at some point
there was a final shot where it appeared
that at that final shot mr brown lost
control
there was a curve in the yard at that
point as you may know
his car went down the ditch across the
street
and collided with the tree uh
when they went to the vehicle we were
able to see when they approached the
vehicle
we counted approximately six if not more
um bullet holes uh in the side
of his car and the passenger side
of his car windows was shattered
we were able to see one shot in the
front windshield and we were able to see
a number of shots approximately
six at least in the back windshield
at no point let me be very clear at no
point did we see mr brown pose a threat
to the law enforcement officers that
were there my friends i would suggest to
you
that it was absolutely and unequivocally
unjustified when they opened the door
there were no weapons found
they pulled his body out of the car
laid him face first
flat on the ground
as you can see the bullet wound that
went into the back of his head
and then they begin to search his home
and so i can't speak on what everybody
else saw
i i don't know what video that they saw
but i can tell you
that what attorney lasseter said was
exactly what we saw today true
all right and so i said this and as i
closed my comments
i said this at the maacp rally
on on last weekend i said something to
the effect of
it's a new day in elizabeth city that's
right that's right
and so with this being said and with us
being able to see
that this has come to the light i i'm
confident that our legal team is is more
committed
now to pursue justice to make sure that
the memory and the legacy of andrew
brown lives
because what we saw today was
unconstitutional and it was not
justifiable
i'm not gonna say before you guys long
um thank you all for listening
i've been told my voice is soft so i
need to speak up a little bit
um
again let's be clear
this was an unjustifiable shooting
i've said it before and i'm standing
here standing by my word
as i said a couple days ago and outside
those court steps
we will seek justice for andrew brown jr
thank you
this is his oldest son caleb furby
uh the video i seen
last week is pretty much the same
as what i've seen today just a few more
details
but he wasn't in the wrong
at all what's in the light what's in the
dark gonna come to the light
you know what i'm saying
it's going to be like that he's going to
get his justice cause
it won't even work
we'll ask questions a second
oh man it's real brief my father did not
deserve to die at all
he did not deserve to get killed in any
way should perform he did not pose any
threat
at all concord there's no way
that this could be justified there's no
way possible
and that's all i gotta say
on behalf of the legal team uh myself
akari sellers and benjamin crump
chancellor lester
our new addition translation as well as
wayne kendall
i am uh i am uh
confused i was teaching my daughter a
new word
convoluted heart for something to
explain
and what i need explaining today is why
you have
killers in pasco taken county that's not
into jail
today all right so
we we had preschool
peaceful protests peaceful
demonstrations
now we know what they were trying to
hide
now we know why they didn't want to
release the tape
now we know why they still don't want to
release the whole chain
what was described by
chance lynch chateau lasser
is a massacre you should be outraged
you should be outraged that in 2021
2021 that a man can be killed
gunned down by a fire squad
now be damned just just because they
wear a shield
a badge that the killer should still
walk free
[Applause]
if it was you myself
we would probably be in the orange
jumpsuit over here waiting for a ring
the tune and the tone
transparency and now we want
accountability and we want justice
and what justice is today but what we
know what they behind
what chantel and khalil saw a couple
weeks ago last week
arrests prosecution
conviction and a lone prison sentence
a long prison sentence somebody say
throw away the key
how you feel hold on one second wait
wait one second somebody asked me to
turn the dance how you feel
can be executed
all this marching all everything we went
through
now i'm not trying to say that one thing
is worse than the other one
but it is clear when you got a man
that's killed on tape
executed murdered the killers should be
brought to justice
and they will be they will be
with that being said i'm gonna open up
for questions brief questions we got a
lot going on
so please be very respectful for our
time
okay did they indicate to you that they
would file charges
there's no indication there's no
indication this time that any charges
will be filed at this time so no not to
us let me also let me also say
let me also say one thing here that the
family is very aware of
uh there is a a huge question
about whether or not this family can get
justice
the way this system is set up here today
we have asked last wednesday we sent a
letter it was certified so i know he
received it
the district attorney here to recuse
himself
from this matter we believe that it's an
incestuous relationship between the
district attorney and law enforcement
he works he works every single day with
these officers
he's worked for years prosecuting cases
with these
officers and his office is literally in
the sheriff's department that's right
we do not believe that we will have a
fair set of eyes reviewing this going
forward and i know that people are
looking for something
to ask for and we're asking that the
community join us
in our request because the way that the
law is set up in north carolina the only
person who can remove a case
is the district attorney himself and so
we're asking him to recuse himself so
this family can have justice yes
khalil did you sit at a desk was it on a
monitor did they rewind it could you
watch it the first time it went by did
they repeat it describe what's happening
yes because you're watching
it yes yes i could
he said yes he could rewind it and look
at it over and over again
so yes that has yes
allow me to say this and to reiterate
what bacardi just said
this district attorney got up before the
courts and made a statement that
not until andrew brown came forward
and made contact then the shooting
started
look at the video look at recording that
is inconsistent
of what we saw in this video
miss lynch she said what happened right
before the shot was fired the first shot
was fire
and after the shot well
let me let me back up when they arrived
on the scene
all of them were yelling different
things some of them were saying
show your hands another was saying get
out
it was so much yelling that we could
barely understand what they were saying
so i can't imagine
what was going through mr brown's mind
with him having to sit there and hear
this
not knowing what to do even with both
hands being shown at all times
when the first shot fired he was sitting
in his car and then he began to back up
at no time did we see him go towards
uh a sheriff's deputy at any time the
first shot was fired and what we saw was
after it was fired he began to back up
because he wanted to get out of there he
was trying to
yes you can see both hands we could
clearly see both hands can you see what
provoked this shot
the first shot can we see
all i can say all i can say is this i
didn't see
mr brown make any movements
or actions that would warrant
law enforcement to fire to protect
themselves or anyone else
let me have a question can i say
something real quick because i just want
to
i think we need to level set here for
one moment
you know for far too long in this
country we've become kind of used
to this cycle and black bodies being in
the street
and i don't think that we truly
understand the pain
that these young men are going through
and i just want us all to take a step
back and take a breath
and understand that this is not just
another case for them
we do this work all the time we fly
around from city to city and cover these
cases all across the country and
tell me how you feel what was your
stomach like did you sleep last night
but for them this is a pain that induces
anger outrage disbelief
shock this is pain for this community
this is pain for black men and women all
across the country so
let's level set for a minute and
understand that this is not just another
case this is not
just another body this is somebody who
was
a father somebody who was a brother and
a nephew
and i think we just have to pause for a
moment and realize that go ahead
tim with abc 11. andrew romble gave me a
statement saying that he's not
basically going to recuse himself he's
confident in his ability to have himself
how do you get the statement
so what is your next step to get relief
i don't know how you i mean i sent the
letter he ever said anything to us
i mean i sent it to him certified i mean
the courtesy would be to call
or email or write another letter i see
more reason why he should recuse himself
he will talk to the press and not the
attorneys
you breaking news to me i can't even
it's uh thank you
uh yeah that he the fact
so let me let me be extremely clear
the only the only people in this matter
who would be disadvantaged if he stays
on this case
are our clients this family
if andrew wamble was to recuse himself
there would be no prejudice
to the officers in this case in fact we
would
be sure that justice could be carried
out without the taint of impropriety
the fact that he will not do that shows
that he has some other interest
and whatever that interest is i do not
know and i'm not here to impugn that
character or whatever that interest may
be
but my number is clearly on the letter
and i would appreciate the common
courtesy of a legal professional
of either emailing us back or calling us
with that response that he gave you
all right couple more questions
[Music]
yes but the marches are going to be
peaceful
that nobody wants to tear up the town
that they live in but they're going to
be peaceful and they're going to be loud
but this also this also is not the
responsibility of this family
right so if you want peace go out here
and give us justice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
his question was was the car moving when
the first shot was fired
what we saw we could not see of all the
videos
of the car not moving it did not move
until that first shot people were not
under threat
no in fact if the car was moving was
moving away from them
it was never moving towards them for
them to fire that first shot
so even with the footage because you've
got to remember we've got a dozen law
enforcement officers coming up with
assault rifles
and and they're crowding around that car
the first shot is moved
i mean the first shot is fired and then
you can see the car moving back after
that
in the red dress right here yes we were
told earlier
tell us who you're with again sharon
with channel
we were told earlier that you guys were
going to see
20 minutes and it was taken down to 16.
i don't know if there was a
clarification with that or
do you feel like some more things were
cut out well
there there were a several minutes to
each video that
added up i don't know i didn't add up
every second and
and determine the exact amount of time i
will tell you
my two things about that is that it was
redacted
it was not all raw footage their faces
were blurred out
um you could not see their faces um even
if they were to turn it was blurred out
we were able to see their uh their
weapons
um but just in all my years of criminal
defense and being
an assistant district attorney i have
never in my life seen
where the defendant gets to choose what
evidence
they show to the world
all right last question right here oh
and then we're going to do we got this
young lady here right to your left too
we'll get you right now
[Music]
i'm sorry i can't hear you the parts of
the videos that never held back two
hours and you guys saw about 20 minutes
did that appear to you to be after
everything happened
the kind of what happened i'm not i'm
not sure
i would be speculating i'm not sure what
they kept from us
what's your question since he hasn't
responded to your refusal the d.a what
are the next steps legally
that you'll take what are the next steps
there
you know unfortunately in north carolina
and i want to i want to also give a
a thanks to many members of the north
carolina state legislature
when we were here a few weeks ago this
family
said that they wanted andrew brown's
name to live on
right now the north carolina state
legislature is examining changes to the
body camera law
as we speak in a bipartisan effort
and that wouldn't happen but for andrew
brown and so we are already making a lot
of the changes we want to see
what we have learned though is that
obstruction of justice is basically
uh codified here in north carolina and
so because we
we really don't have many options other
than to take the deck as it's given to
us
we're going to raise a lot of hell and a
lot of noise about the fact that
wumbo wants to stay on this case and if
he chooses to stay on this case we're
going to ask him
to make sure that he follows through
with prosecuting the officers that
murdered
andrew brown unfortunately we don't have
many options but we're going to go out
here and continue to raise our voices
we're going to go out here and continue
to fight and many of the changes that
we've seen
whether or not it's the this body camera
act or the george floyd justice and
policing act we're going to continue to
push forward
to make these changes on behalf of the
family of andrew brown jr
we are this family's getting out of here
we're going to ask that you
uh at least give them the opportunity
without yelling questions at them
just yell questions at the lawyers
they're used to it they can take it
allow khalil and jarrod and uh and their
and their mother and
aunts to please get out of here if we
can't
america don't run cause cops kill
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone